selon le pentagone les forces russes
avancent en ce moment sur trois grands
axes notamment vers la capitale
ukrainienne
on va tout de suite retrouvé à kiev
culliver craag notre correspondant
gulliver bonsoir des unités militaires
russes ont pénétré dans la région de
kiev depuis la biélorussie
le président ukrainien a assuré que les
russes avaient pris un aéroport
militaires aux portes de la ville
oui les ukrainiens affirment avoir
repoussé cette attaque sur l'aérodrome
de rohff tome elle qui est juste aux
portes de kiev au nord ouest de la ville
mais en ce moment on entend des avions
passé au dessus de nous l'attak continue
y compris très près de kiev dans la
région de kiev ce n'est pas uniquement à
vos mails qu'il y a eu des combats sur
terre à l'hosto mail c'était eux d'après
ce taux n'a pu comprendre des ils sont
arrivés en hélicoptère ils ont descendu
l'armée ukrainienne affirme avoir
abattus
3-2 au moins 3 2 34 hélicoptères qui
était arrivé mais il ya eu aussi des
forces qui ont pénétré qui ont traversé
la frontière depuis la biélorussie
toujours dans la région de kiev dans la
zone d'exclusion de tchernobyl
du leader le maire de kiev imposé un
couvre-feu à la ville quel est l'état
d'esprit en ce moment de la population
on a vu sur les images qui nous
parviennent beaucoup d'habitants de la
capitale tenté de fuir
oui il y a beaucoup de gens qui essayent
de fuir il y a beaucoup de gens je pense
ce soir qui se demande s'il n'aurait pas
dû fuir pendant qu'il faisait encore
jour les gens ont très peur je pense que
le poufre peu le feu
les gens resteraient chez eux de toute
façon parce qu'ils ont peur de chartres
à sortir là pendant la nuit avec ses
avions qui passent au dessus tout à
l'heure j'étais à la gare routière
peut-être d'épicés j'ai envoyé quelques
interviews depuis là-bas et je peux vous
dire que juste au moment où j'ai quitté
les lieux il y a eu les sirènes qui ont
retenti et les gens que vous voyez dans
mon reportage en fait une grande partie
d'entre eux en tout cas et s'est enfui
vers la cara ferroviaire qui se trouve
non loin de là
la gare qui est aussi un lieu où les
gens essayent de fuir tombe bien que mal
mais c'est plutôt des gens qui sont dans
l'est de l'ukraine qui essayent de venir
vers kiev ou vers l'ouest et la
compagnie de chemin de fer ukrainien a
mis en place des trains spéciaux
d'évacuation c'est beaucoup oliver
fringants en direct de kiev la capitale
ukrainienne christine